um how's the album coming along it's
actually like uh mixing mastering
finished so it's done like you're not
turning anything new in yeah no no when
you do like well I can't say that
because if if when verses come through
last minute yeah if you get a crazy
verse at the end of the Finish Line I'm
gonna put it on in terms of your parts
my part is done my part is done when you
like put out no my part is never all the
way done I might seek inspiration
tomorrow and just add one in there for a
um surprise so Wednesday I'm dropping
you're here so you're obviously working
I mean oh yeah it's it's so it's pretty
much sealed up
do have you let the name fly yet no but
I'm it's I'm so happy about the name are
you I can't tell you yet but
is the artwork done yes oh yes
for you like do you feel like because
you've put out some big singles
when you drop the album and you have
like a song like London or besito with a
with G herbo are those like bonus tracks
are you working those into the track
listing of the album
um those
I feel like I put him at the end so they
count towards the whole thing dude you
got to pull the French Montana it
depends that what besito was not on this
album
so it's not going to be on like at the
end it's a no but Sita was on was it on
the last box yeah oh it was on the
deluxe okay yeah so London will be on
this one maybe
well yeah for sure it will be on this
one duh
yeah it is yeah you got to put it on
there no it is London will be on this
one but that's probably like the only
record in um well London and I'm that
is there um
there any features you can reveal
no none only because like I just like
surprises some surprises yeah like I
like to just like
let it let it come out how big of a
surprise
I like big surprises you know me like a
stadium surprise or like a House of
Blues across I like a big surprise okay
I like a little Razzle Dazzle every now
and then any Boston features
not on this one but me and Millie's will
definitely do a song we've been trying
to find the time his schedule and my
schedule is like crazy
Millie's is uh he's having a moment
right now he's incredible like I'm so
happy for him I met him in uh a South by
Southwest in like 2013 at the hotel
lobby he came up to me and was like I
watch your on two dope boys and not
right now that's what's up I didn't
again a long journey yeah I'm so happy
to see like everybody like around the
world really catch on him too because
he's really so genuine and just so good
at what he does
it's like
people need to know about him who would
you put on the Boston hip or let's just
say Massachusetts because we if Joyner
Lucas is not from Boston who's on the
Mount Rushmore of of if you had to
exclude yourself because you're up there
but
um
Massachusetts as a state Massachusetts
yes I would go like Legends too like
I'll put Guru of course I would do like
uh a lot of people don't know gurus from
Boston and Primos from Texas
um
that's a hard one man uh that's a tough
one
would you let Benzino sniff it just take
a sniff sniff what the Mount Rushmore of
Boston or Massachusetts hip-hop would
you let him at least
would you at least like invite him to
the you gotta be
I mean like would you let him sniff the
list would you like consider him
I mean the source was big you know made
man yeah of course um yo The Source in
itself the almighty RSO you know yeah no
like for sure like yeah Benzino
he's definitely important to the culture
he's important yeah absolutely you're on
there
gurus on there
I don't I don't like this question
Joyner Lucas is on there yeah for sure
I'll let you I'll let you pick the
Rushmore and I'll just say give you
thumbs
can we go non-rappers yeah please static
selector static selector number one okay
terminology terminology is up there yeah
like shout out to turn man forgetting
I love that I don't know it's like I'm
so
I gotta like tap more back into the
Boston scene because there's a lot of
cousin stizzes from there who was uh
Michael Christmas uh I know way too much
about what's the what's the guy's name
who's named after beer oh is it Samuel
Adams from there Sammy Adams
I missed that whole
but shout out to him
but you're up there yeah are we
considering koi from Boston is she from
Boston she has roots for sure yeah she's
from she's kind of like Boston in Jersey
have you and her uh got to link up and
connect and yeah we're real cool like
outside of music too yeah she's she
seems like a great energy yeah I love
her she's super genuine and like I'm
super happy for her as well